[Music]
all right tv night with my pro
[Applause]
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh
hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is i have an owner
he's superman and um
[Music]
my dog is the best
but he's not the greatest with other
animals this just seems gross we need
gross smelling stuff is one of the
greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs sasha never feed us
chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
but we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumb on the back
it's deployed canines here what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why could i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squishy bros
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
so
you are a dog
i am the batman
i'm not really great with animals yeah
i'm not really great with people
probably because of my traumatic
puppyhood as a child my family was taken
from me as a puppy i was taken from my
family so i steal myself my emotions
always check no one ever getting past my
impenetrable defenses
[Music]
ah what the heck
that can't be sanitary
everyday me and suits hang out
you literally worship the ground that
dude walks on technically he flies
batman works alone except for robin and
alfred commissioner gordon my eye t crew
whoever morgan freeman played what do i
have here spoilers
squeezy what
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
wake up buddy it is o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i have an owner and the superman let me
just iron that out i should call me iron
man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who was he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so
long well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oink
[Music]
i'm the only one who didn't get any
superpowers
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
just which is crazy i didn't even know
that was a thing but it's like a dog
water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy canine here what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
[Music]
you